hey I'm Tony Hawk and welcome to skate
support okay we go is there a
skateboarding trick called the eggplant
yes there is a skateboarding trick
called the eggplant I'll show you how to
do it right now
[Music]
over there I'm gonna do a regular hand
plant and then here I'll do an eggplant
hopefully you can spot the difference we
call a hand plant or invert is done by
using your front hand to grab the board
on your toe side and then using your
trailing hand to actually stand on the
coping and that's how you balance that's
a hand planet here's an eggplant an
eggplant is reversing those hands so
using your back hand to grab the board
your front hand to actually balance your
body and doing the same direction of
turning bro I need some advice on how to
do a 540 on a skateboard my first advice
to you is learn how to skate quarter
pipes
preferably bigger ones because the
bigger the quarter pipe the more airtime
you can actually get and have to spin a
full 540 rotation I'll show you a
McTwist actually a version of 540 right
now this is a 540 on vert I'm gonna grab
my board on my toe side which we call
mute around my leg we call it that tuck
knee and if you do a 540 grabbing this
way assuming you go upside down a little
bit that's me twist it's one of the
scariest things to learn because when
you start to do it you're blind to
landing for a half a rotation so you
kind of gotta use the force so I will
say just get used to that spin until you
actually start to land it
[Music]
hey Tony how can you please make another
Pro Skater video again my contract is up
with Activision they own the license to
that actual name Tony Hawk's Pro Skater
if we can come to some new agreement
absolutely yes I'm in hi Activision free
agent right here let's do some more fun
stuff how do you do a boardslide on a
bench rail or pipe on a skateboard I can
show you the difference between a
boardslide on a rail and a boardslide
on a ramp right now you approach some
sort of ledge and then you slide using
only the board the wheels are off the
ground
[Music]
this is what a boardslide looks like on
vert
let's see which skateboarding trick was
the hardest to learn McTwist 540's it
took me nearly ten years to figure out
how to do in 901 of the tricks that I've
only done a couple times in my life is a
kickflip McTwist we just actually like
my board does a kickflip and I catch it
in the middle of McTwist and there are
so many things happening all at once
that it's almost like the planets have
to align for it to work out perfectly
years of struggle with that trick only
to land to on video does anyone know how
to set up a skateboard I have all the
stuff just none of the tools or
knowledge I do know how to set up a
skateboard what you need is skateboard
trucks wheels bearings and hardware okay
so the first thing you do get a
skateboard stripper grip tape you want
to take the backing off get the sticky
part down push the grip tape on from the
center aisle so that you don't get too
many air bubbles if you do get our
bubbles take a box cutter or exacto and
just slice them and put them down and no
one will ever know that you didn't know
what you're doing place the grip tape
get it flat cut it around the edges
don't cut too hard in another Sun you
don't know what you're doing then you
want to poke holes through the grip tape
if you wear all the trucks go put the
hardware through on top of the grip tape
take your trucks so that the kingpins
are facing in next you want to attach
the wheels and I'm gonna give you my
little handy tip for putting wheels on
take two bearings you got the outer part
of the bearing and the inner part of the
bearing outer part is sealed put the
inner part facing up two bearings like
this take your wheel face down put on
one bearing turn it over put on the
other bearing put your spacer on and
that's it and your wheels already good
to go I give away my skateboard so much
for auctions for charities and people I
had to learn how to break in new
skateboards constantly and now that's
more what I'm used to every other pro
swears by their trucks and how they turn
and will hold on to them at any cost I
give them away this is a technical
question it says three flip is that the
same as a tray flip and how can you do a
varial flip but not a kickflip isn't
very ill a shove it kickflip that is a
loaded question okay a three flip is a
nickname for a 360 flip also known as a
tray flip so yes all of those are the
same nomenclature a kickflip is when you
actually just flip your board all around
right a 360 flip is when the board does
a full 360 rotation and a kickflip a
very
flip is half that so a varial flip is a
180 kickflip can you end up with more
backwards
how do you even kickflip a normal board
how do you even stand on a skateboard
without eating well those are two
very different questions I'll take the
second one first how do you stand on a
skateboard without eating Center
your weight and anticipate the motion
that's gonna be the best way to be on a
skateboard without actually falling off
that if you just stand the skateboard
stationary it tends to be a little too
wobbly and there's not much leverage
that you get from that tighten the
trucks cuz you wanna be super wobbly use
your back foot to push off and stand
with your weight centers and make sure
you're anticipating the motion let's see
how do you even kickflip a normal board
the idea of a kickflip is using your
front foot to get the board flipping so
while you're sliding your front foot to
level out your board you actually slide
it off of the edge of the board and that
gets it flipping and the ideas you want
it to be flipping while you're still
going up so you catch with your feet and
then you put it down it should be that
easy but it's not I don't know why but
recently I'm tempted to get a skateboard
but I think I'd look ridiculous
any advice on a starter board or rig
midlifecrisis
okay I'm gonna guess that you're
somewhere between 30 and 50 a starter
board it has sort of a distinct nose you
know sort of a shovel nose in a wider
tail some bigger wheels maybe something
a little softer so you can cruise down
the street as well as riding in the
parks just start slow you know I don't
think it's ever too late to start and
it's a great way of exercise so good
luck Tony Hawk how do you do and only a
nollie is the basis of most skate tricks
it's the way you lift the board up in
the air using your feet I can show you
how to ollie on flat and I can show you
how to ollie on vert like this
[Music]
snap the tail and it was sliding from
foot simultaneously to bring the tail up
that's an ollie
[Music]
calling on veut is a totally different
technique you're lifting up from a
vertical plane so you're using friction
way more and you're actually like
floating and putting pressure on your
board a lot more to keep it in the air
because you're considerably higher than
you are on the flat it says why can't
you skateboard when you're 40
well I'm 49 the end okay this is a good
one it says dude you're the best you
have inspired me to skateboard please I
have one question what was your first
skateboarding trick the first thing I
ever learned on ski bruh where I felt
like I learned a trick was going up a
curb I learned how to rock my board up a
curb and then put my foot closer to the
nose and actually lift my back wheels up
to clear the curb and I think that's
what sparks my interest in getting to
the skatepark and learning tricks I
still love doing it
[Music]
alright well that was skate support with
wired and this is Tony Hawk thanks for
watching